that's right
the White House has described
now we understand the president is
falling this because he has the Chinese
fires but should also be pointed out and
our viewers should know going into this
when the president makes those kinds of
remarks he is praised China he is
praised
ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
thank you very much everybody
please hope it's not too hot but it's
pretty warm thank you
so we've had a big day in the stock
market things are coming back and
they're coming back very rapidly a lot
sooner than people thought people are
feeling good about our country people
are feeling good about therapeutics and
possible vaccines but we're going to go
over a quite a bit and maybe at the end
we'll take some questions that we have
time it's not too hot today I signed
legislation and an executive order to
hold China accountable for its
oppressive actions against the people of
Hong Kong the Hong Kong autonomy Act
which I signed this afternoon passed
unanimously through Congress this law
gives my administration powerful new
tools to hold responsible the
individuals and the entities involved in
extinguishing Hong Kong's freedom we've
all watched what happened not a good
situation their freedoms been taken away
their rights have been taken away and
with it goes hong kong in my opinion
because it will no longer be able to
compete with free markets a lot of
people will be leaving hong kong i
suspect and we're going to do a lot more
business because of it because we just
lost one competitor it's the way it is
we lost a very very serious competitor
competitor that we incentivize to take a
lot of business and do well and we gave
them a lot of business by doing what we
did we gave them things that nobody else
had the right to do and that gave them a
bigoted edge over other markets and
because of that edge they've done really
historic business tremendous business
far bigger than anybody would have
thought years ago when we did this gift
we it was really a gift to freedom today
I also signed an executive order ending
us preferential treatment for Hong Kong
Hong Kong will now be treated the same
as mainland China no special privileges
no special economic treatment and no
export of sensitive technologies in
addition to that as you know we're
placing massive tariffs and have placed
very large tariffs on China first time
that's ever happened to China
billions of dollars have been paid to
the United States of which I've given
quite a bit to the farmers and ranchers
of our country because they were
targeted and that's been going on for
three years
first time anybody's ever done anything
like that and prior to the plague
pouring in from China they were having
the worst years you know in 67 years and
I don't want them to have a bad year I
want them to have a good year but they
would taking advantage of the United
States for many many years and that's
stopping but then the then the virus
came in and the world is a different
place but we're now getting back and one
of the reasons the markets doing so it's
almost at the point that it was at prior
to the plague almost we're getting very
close it's a great thing it's an amazing
thing what our people have done and what
they've endured no administration has
been tougher on China than this
administration we imposed historic
tariffs we stood up to China's
intellectual property theft at a level
that nobody's ever come close we
confronted untrustworthy Chinese
technology and telecom providers we
convinced many countries many countries
and I did this myself for the most part
not to use Huawei because we think it's
an unsafe security risk it's a big
security risk
I talked many countries out of using it
if they want to do business with us they
can't use it just today I believe that
UK announced that they're not going to
be using it
and that was up in the air for a long
time but they've decided and you look at
Italy you look at many other countries
we withdrew from the Chinese dominated
WHL and we fully rebuilt the United
States military the WHL World Health
Organization we were paying close to 500
million dollars a year China was paying
39 million dollars a year and China had
too much say they worked it very hard
which is a bad thing done by our past
administrations but we were tough and we
were saying I was asking I said why are
we paying so much more than China China
has 1.4 billion people we have 325
probably 325 million approximately
nobody can give the exact count we're
trying to get an exact count but you
have over the years many illegals who
have come into the country so it depends
on how you want to count it but you
could say 325 to 350 million people as
opposed to 1.4 billion people and the
world trade world trade is terrible that
deal is terrible of the world health is
terrible deal we've been very tough in
the World Trade Organization and we've
been I guess as tough as you can get on
world health we withdrew our money we
told them we're getting out doesn't mean
that someday we won't go back in maybe
we will when it's correctly run but they
made a lot of bad predictions and they
said a lot of bad things about what to
do and how to do it and they turned out
to be wrong and they were really a
puppet of China and make no mistake we
hold China fully responsible for
concealing the virus and unleashing it
upon the world
it could have stopped it they should
have stopped it would have been very
easy to do at the source when it
happened in contrast Joe Biden's entire
career has been a gift to the Chinese
Communist Party and to the calamity of
of errors that they've made they made so
many errors
and it's been devastating for the
American worker China has taken out
hundreds of billions of dollars a year
from our country and we rebuilt China
give them all the credit in the world I
don't give the credit for the people
that used to stand here because they
allowed this to happen where hundreds of
billions of dollars were taken out of
the United States Treasury in order to
rebuild China there's no company and no
country in the world no country in the
world has ever ripped off the United
States like the incredible job that they
did on this country and the people that
ran it possibly it's one of the reasons
certainly it's one of the very big
reasons trade and things related to
trade that I got elected in the first
place I've been talking about it for a
long time along with many other subjects
frankly Joe Biden supported China's
entry into the World Trade Organization
one of the greatest geopolitical and
economic disasters in world history if
you look at China you look at the moment
they joined the world trade they were
flatlining for years and years and years
and decades and then all of a sudden
they joined the World Trade Organization
and they went like a rocket ship they
were given all sorts of advantages they
were considered a developing country as
a developing country they got tremendous
advantages over the United States and
other countries and they took advantage
of those advantages and and then some
Biden personally led the effort to give
China permanent most favored nation
status which is a tremendous advantage
for a country to have few countries have
it but the United States doesn't have it
never did probably never even asked for
it because they didn't know what they
were doing as Vice President Biden was a
leading advocate of the Paris climate
Accord which was unbelievably expensive
to our country would have crushed
American manufacturers
while allowing China to pollute pollute
the atmosphere with impunity yet one
more gift from Biden to the Chinese
Communist Party they took all of the
advantage away from us they took
everything away
they don't have oil we would have had it
closed up tremendous amounts of our
energy to qualify eventually not too far
into the future we would have had to do
things that would have been unbelievably
destructive to our country including the
possible closing of 25% of our
businesses think of that and it was
going to cost us hundreds and hundreds
of millions of dollars for the privilege
of being involved in the Paris climate
Accord and you just have to look at what
took place this year in Paris and France
where money was being sent to countries
all over the world and the people of
France didn't want to take it and they
didn't and they did a lot of rioting had
their taxes raised we would have had to
raise our taxes and it was a disaster
I've been given a lot of credit for what
I did there took a certain amount of
courage I guess because it sounds so
nice the Paris climate Accord but it
wasn't good for us at all America lost
nearly 10,000 factories while Joe Biden
was vice president think of that 10,000
factories he wrote something today and
he made a statement today that I wrote
down pretty accurate so Biden was here
for 47 years eight years the last eight
years not long ago as vice president he
said one in five miles of our highways
are still in poor condition well we're
doing a good job in highways but why
didn't he fix them three years ago why
didn't he fix him tens of thousands of
bridges are in disrepair and on the
verge of collapse well it's probably not
a right number but we have bridges it
should have been fixed
why didn't he fix him it was there for
eight years with President Obama why
didn't they fix him tens of thousands of
bridges this is what he wrote high-speed
broadband we want high-speed where well
why didn't he get it three years ago
it's not a long time and he didn't do
any of the things but now he says he's
gonna be president and as president he's
going to do all the things that he
didn't do he never did never did
anything except make very bad decisions
especially on foreign policy so Joe
Biden in President Obama
freely allowed China to pillage our
factories plunder our communities and
steal our most precious secrets and I've
stopped it largely but I've stopped it
and it wasn't easy because you talk
about a certain power of the telephone
and the calls where they would call and
say no we don't want to do that other
countries would call on behalf of China
but I did it I did what has to be done
and you just take a look at what's gone
on and take a look at the kind of at the
numbers where they devalued their
currency in order to pay the tariffs now
the Democrat Party is calling for
defunding of our military think of that
defunding they want to defund our
military when China is building a
massive military they're building a
massive military and Biden wants to
defund our military and the world needs
American strength right now more than
ever and we've got it we've we've got
now soon as it all this equipment comes
in all made in the USA we've got the
newest most incredible weapons anywhere
in the world we have the best tanks the
best ships the best missiles rockets we
have the best of everything we have the
best fighter jets the f-35 the f-18 all
of these assets of being built anchors
credible tankers bombers hope we don't
have to use them but we have
the most incredible military when I came
in the military was totally depleted it
was it was at a level that was just
absolutely incredible
you know the statements I made the
statements before I told you what
generals told me about our military and
I'll make him again if somebody needs
him we'll give him to you very
well-documented as Vice President Biden
opposed tariffs and he was standing up
for China didn't want to do anything to
disrupt the relationship with China even
though China was taking us to the
cleaners he opposed my very strict
travel ban on Chinese nationals to stop
the spread of the China virus he was
totally against it xenophobic he called
me xenophobic a month later he admitted
I was right we would have had thousands
of people additionally die if we let
people come in from heavily infected
China but we stopped it we did a travel
ban in January Nancy Pelosi was dancing
in the streets of Chinatown in San
Francisco a month later and even later
than that and others too they all
thought what I did was a terrible
mistake we would have lost track doctor
foul Qi said he would have lost
thousands of additional people if
President Trump had to do that and I was
a crowd of one because even experts
didn't want to do it they thought it was
a mistake and then I did Europe when I
started seeing what was going on in
Italy and Spain and France and other
countries in Europe I did a ban on
people coming in from Europe that would
have been disastrous for our country
also and we saved tens of thousands of
lives but we actually saved millions of
lives by closing by closing up we saved
millions potentially millions of lives
could be a number that we're actually
working on but it could be two to three
million lives so we're at a hundred and
thirty five thousand which is terrible
one is too much but we would have had
millions of people dead from this
curse that came at us but we did what we
had to do and now we'll put out the
flames as it as it happens we have to
get the schools open we have to get
everything open a lot of people don't
want to do that for political reasons
not for other reasons but if we had
listened to Joe Biden hundreds of
thousands of additional lives would have
been lost and if you look at the job he
did on swine flu I looked at a poll that
polls on everything nowadays and he they
got very bad marks on the job they did
on the swine flu h1n1 he calls it N one
H one h1n1 got very poor marks from
Gallup on the job they did on swine flu
and they stopped very early on testing
they totally stopped it they just said
stuff and frankly if we didn't test you
wouldn't have all the headlines because
we're showing cases and we have just
about the lowest mortality rate but if
we did think of this if we didn't do
testing instead of testing over 40
million people if we did half the
testing would have half the cases if we
did another you cut that in half would
have yet again half of that but the
headlines are always testing now the
testing is a good thing but at the same
time it's it's fodder for the fake news
to report cases so we're doing 40
million plus gonna be very close to 45
million people and when I turn on the
news I see cases cases cases they don't
talk about deaths being cut down to a
level that actually tenfold they use I
got that from one of the very respected
media outlets tenfold cut tenfold this
but they don't talk about that they talk
about cases and the cases are created
because of the fact that we do
tremendous tests and we're the best
testing in the world we now make
ventilators for the world we had very
few ventilators there wasn't one person
in any hospital anywhere in this country
that needed a ventilator that didn't
and that was because we mobilized to a
level using the purchasing act in some
cases we mobilized to a level that
nobody thought possible nothing's
happened like that since World War two
our task force has done a great job Mike
Pence worked so hard it gets so little
credit sad to see that actually but he
worked so hard get so little credit
the governor's would tell us would be on
the phone with 50 different governors
they'd all tell us what a great job
great job and then they'll go to the
media and say well they didn't do such a
good job well we did a great job we made
a lot of Governors look fantastic we did
in New York what we did in New York was
one of the most incredible things 2,800
bed and Javits Center but the governor
used very few of them unfortunately then
we moved in a great hospital ship one of
our two great we move one also to Los
Angeles and we could have used that for
our senior citizens we could have used
it for other people they could have used
it instead of sending our seniors back
into nursing homes that were infected
where you lost thousands of people
thousands of people in New York died
because of poor management by the
governor and it's a very sad thing to
see and very sad to watch and very sad
to look at those statistics but we have
a we have an incredible Javits Center
that we built with thousands of beds I
think it was 2800 all ready to go and
they could have sent people there or
they could have sent senior citizens
there instead of sending them into the
nursing homes and after all of that work
and getting it done the Army Corps of
engineer I mean the job they did was
incredible they built it in a matter of
days when it was all completed FEMA
everybody was there doctors we ended up
getting doctors they said we can't man
it he said so we'll man it and woman it
and that's what we did we brought in
doctors nurses everything we're all set
we said where are the people they didn't
send the people very few people came in
they could have sent him into the Javits
Center they could have sent him to the
hospital ship which was virtually unused
but
we were there by contrast my
administration acted very early to ban
travel from China from Europe saving all
of these lives credible and I want
everyone to know I want every citizen
know that we're using the full power of
the federal government to fight the
China virus and to keep our people safe
through operation warp-speed we will
deliver a vaccine and record-breaking
time we're doing very well on the
vaccines we have many many different
vaccines being studied right now many of
which are looking really good and we're
ready to distribute the vaccine when we
get it we're all set taking a risk and
economic risk of preparing for delivery
because we feel very certain it's going
to be there but logistically we have our
military ready to go we have generals
that that's all they do is distribute
things and they're going to be
distributed hopefully a vaccine or a
therapeutic and it's coming out really
well and I think you're gonna have some
good news very very quickly having to do
with the vaccines we're also working
with many other countries on the vaccine
many countries are working with us we're
unleashing our nation's scientific
genius to kill the virus Joe Biden
didn't just side with China on the virus
he did he called me again xenophobic
that's what he said you all heard it
many times he described the rise of
China as quote a very positive
development not a positive development
not for us it's not he said that the
idea that China is our competition is
really bizarre he's really bizarre
he said China is not a problem no
nobody's ripped us off more than China
over the last 25 30 years nobody close
and he says China's not a problem now he
takes it all back now he wants to be mr.
tough guy but for years 47 years he
never came out against China and never
said I think that just the opposite his
son walked out with 1.5 billion dollars
of money to invest where he'll make
hundreds of thousands of dollars maybe
men
millions of dollars a year walked out
with 1.5 billion I asked one of the
biggest people on Wall Street
maybe the biggest is that possible he
said no he's never seen it they don't do
that but hunter where's hunter where is
hunter by the way hunter Biden walked
out with 1.5 billion in Ukraine he got
eighty three thousand dollars a month
and I guess an upfront payment of three
million dollars so he went from not
having a job to getting eighty three
thousand dollars a month with a lot of
money paid upfront to work for the rispa
and you all know about purissima but
nothing happens nobody cares and he was
unemployed as you know he was
unfortunately forced to leave the
military was forced to live didn't have
a job and all of a sudden he's making a
fortune but nobody talks about that
indeed Biden expressed more fawning
praise about China on an ordinary day
than about America on the 4th of July
the last independence they Biden
attacked the United States and said we
had quote never lived up to the ideals
of our fathers our forefathers or our
founding fathers those founding ideals
and yet he enthusiastically stated that
China is a great nation and we should
hope for its continued expansion well we
all wish well to China but what China's
unleashed on the world it's it's hard to
even fathom
I see people now friends of mine they
woke up they want to say hello and have
to keep their distance and they were all
covered up like you're all covered up
with face masks it's a different world
but we're coming out on top Biden sides
with China over America time and time
again and he said on the 4th of July
American history is no fairy tale
and yet blindly celebrates China saying
few nations in history have come so far
so fast he's so proud of them
he's so proud of them now Joe Biden is
pushing a platform that would demolish
the US economy totally demolish it so we
built the greatest economy in the
history of our country greatest in the
history of the world that was a few
months ago best unemployment numbers
ever best for african-american
asian-american Hispanic America best for
women best for everybody best for young
people that didn't have a high school
diploma didn't have a college diploma
they had a diploma they were really in
good shape
we built the greatest ever stock market
highest ever in history we had 143 days
of all time stock market highs in just
less than three and a half years and we
had to close it down because we did the
right thing by doing that as I said we
saved millions of lives but China was
saying this is incredible what's going
on China was for the first time
respecting the United States and now
they want to do something that's much
different Joe Biden so I've watched this
and I've watched it with great interest
we're building in our economy again I
guess the stock market went up almost
500 points today or something they're
about so check but it was up a lot when
I left and our economy is coming back
we're almost at a level where even
though it's long before the very
important maybe the most important ever
election of November 3rd but long before
that but we're close to record stock
markets again and Nasdaq hit an all-time
high for the 16th time I think of that
for the 16th time over the last month or
so for the 16th times so one of our
markets already hit an all-time high
today Joe Biden gave a speech in which
he said that the core of his economic
agenda is a hard left crusade against
American energy he wants to kill
American energy
he wants to reenter the unfair one-sided
Paris climate Accord which will destroy
us at the expense of many other nations
who benefit it was actually drawn in my
opinion to take advantage of the United
States just like so many other deals are
done to take advantage of the fools
running the United States but this would
do nothing for the environment but would
[ __ ] American industry while greatly
helping China he wants to impose a
massive energy taxes and job crushing
mandates to eliminate carbon from the
United States economy let him define the
word carbon because he won't be able to
obliterating American oil clean coal
natural gas and the natural energy
resources that supply supply countless
American jobs Joe Biden put a OH see a
young woman not talented in many ways in
charge of his energy plan and the
environment essentially her and Bernie
Sanders who ran a lot of times the
president never made it good base but
that's about it in other words he wants
to impose the green new deal on our
country when I first saw the green New
Deal I thought it was a joke I said this
will never go anywhere now they're
trying to impose it this will destroy
our country and make us non-competitive
with other countries don't forget word
competition with China and with many
other countries throughout the world
we're in tremendous economic competition
including Europe which has never treated
us well the European Union was formed in
order to take advantage of the United
States they formed and they take
advantage of the United States and I
know that they know I know that but
other presidents had no idea
last week Joe Biden released his unity
platform developed with socialist Bernie
Sanders describing what he would do if
elected president the Biden Sanders
agenda is agenda is the most extreme
platform of any major party nominee by
far in American history I think it's
worse than actually Bernie's platform
it's gone so far right and he's doing
that because he's begging for that vote
but one of the things I just asked my
people to do is just drop for me just
quickly some of the things that we've
been hearing about over the last couple
of weeks and these are actual key
elements of the biden sanders unity
platform abolish immigration detention
no more detention you come in here
illegally no more detention
stop all deportations so if we get a
ms-13 gang member which we've taken out
of our country by the thousands brought
them back to Honduras Guatemala can do
that any more El Salvador can't do that
any more stop all deportations others
will take all of these people many of
whom are in prison for rape murder lots
of other things and prosecution of
illegal border crossers okay they come
in illegally and we have to stop the
whole process support the deadly
sanctuary cities where many of these
people are protected better than the
American citizen is protected
incentivize illegal alien child
smuggling give it an incentive because
if you look at what they're saying
that's exactly what they do
incentivize illegal alien child
smuggling they're incentivized by what
this plan calls for expand asylum for
all new illegal aliens how about that
one
all new illegal aliens expand asylum
cancel all asylum cooperation agreements
in the Western Hemisphere well we have
agreements with Honduras Guatemala with
El Salvador we have great agreements
where when Biden and Obama used to bring
killers out they would say don't bring
them back to our country we don't want
them what we have to we don't
they wouldn't take him now with us
they'd take him someday I'll tell you
why someday I'll tell you why but they
take him and they take him very gladly
they used to bring them out and they
wouldn't even let the airplanes land if
they brought him back by airplanes they
wouldn't let the buses into their
country they said we don't want him he
said no but they entered our country
illegally and they're murderers they're
killers in some cases and they said nope
we don't want them they'd turn the bus
around that turned the plane around then
that land in the United States and who
knows what happened to him but it wasn't
good
taxpayer-funded lawyers will be given to
all illegal aliens so we're going to pay
now for the lawyers Lobby and we're
going to give all illegal aliens
taxpayer-funded lawyers how does that
sound pretty good
in other words come in here illegally
we're going to give you a free legal
advice we'll take you up to the Supreme
Court as much as possible abolish
immigration enforcement against illegal
workers think of that abolish
immigration enforcement they're going to
abolish immigration enforcement well
basically as you know what they're going
to do is it going to rip down the wall -
taking it down they want to take down
the wall which we fought hard for up to
259 miles right now of great powerful
wall that's really working because if
you look at the numbers in addition to
the fact that Mexico for various reasons
has 27,000 soldiers on our southern
border to keep people out of our country
and I appreciate we had a great meeting
last week with the President of Mexico
great guy friend of mine become a friend
of mine a lot of people thought that
couldn't happen because we're very
opposite in terms of our views maybe
even in terms of our temperament but
he's a great guy and he's a friend of
mine and they've been terrific Mexico
has been terrific 27,000 soldiers on our
border Mexican soldiers and we have
great great numbers we get rid of so
many different things catch-and-release
is God so many different things have
taken place we used to catch them take
their name and release them into our
country we don't do that anymore we now
release them back where they came from
sometimes we'll bring them back to their
country grant work permits for illegal
aliens so if you come in illegally you
get a work permit people that live here
don't get work permits many cases
provide taxpayer subsidies and welfare
for illegal aliens and new immigrants so
we want to provide taxpayer subsidies
and welfare for people that come into
our country illegally illegal immigrants
they want government health care for all
illegal aliens this is part of their
plan I'm not making this up this is all
down in their plan from last week and
this is good compared to what I heard
today federal student aid and free
Community College for illegal aliens
what do you think about that federal
student aid and free Community College
we're gonna have every person in the
world pouring into our country from all
over the world and by the way the wall
was so timely because it staffed people
coming in from heavily infected areas of
Mexico if we had that we would be in
trouble like you wouldn't believe you
wouldn't believe
and remember cases is different than
deaths and cases we give you because our
testing is the best in the world and by
the way by far the most 45 million find
out which country tested forty five
million people if China if Russia if
India tested forty five million people
or if they did test like we did check
out how many cases they'd have but it's
still we've done a great job get no
credit for it and I don't want the
credit I want the people that have done
this great job the people that have done
such an incredible job when building the
ventilators and doing the testing and
building a testing platform that's been
amazing we have many platforms many
companies have come up with different
forms of tests when we started there was
no such thing sign new immigrants up for
welfare immediately this is Joe Biden so
they walk off and they come in and they
two foot into our land and we sign up
new immigrants up for welfare we sign
them up immediately they get welfare
benefits United States citizens don't
get what they're looking to give illegal
immigrants think of that sign up it's
hard to believe I'm even reading that
new immigrants for welfare immediately
not to mention the cost of this which is
incalculable the cost of this is so
crazy and requirement for immigrant
self-sufficiency and maximize their
welfare now this is us writing this
who's not coming to the United States
every person from South America is going
to pour in every person from other
countries they're going to be pouring in
and requirement think of that for
immigrant self-sufficiency and remember
to maximize welfare so we give it a
maximum then we have massively expand
immigration during a global pandemic
taking jobs from unemployed Americans
into all travel bans including from
jihadist regions so now we have travel
bans a lot of you said I didn't get the
travel ban and you were wrong we got the
travel ban we lost in the ninth circuit
we lost again in the ninth circuit and
then we won in the Supreme Court we have
a very strong travel ban and we don't
want people that are going to come in
and blow up our cities do things and
frankly with the with the Liberal
Democrats running the cities that we do
have where they do have problems maybe
they wouldn't mind but I would mind and
the people of this country mind so
listen to this and all travel bans he's
talking about the band that I want that
everybody said I didn't when they said I
didn't win because in the lower court we
lost that we lost in the Appellate
Division and then we won in the Supreme
Court she said he lost and they're right
at the lower level but in the meantime
we wanted this
so it's in effect but they didn't say
that they said he lost which again is
fake news but that's the way they do it
so into all travel bans including from
jihadist regions they specify that grant
mass amnesty everybody gets amnesty mass
amnesty think of that and this is create
a road map to citizenship for massive
massive numbers and we're not talking
about daca because I'm going to take
care of daca much better than the
Democrats did the Democrats had their
chance and they blew it but we're gonna
take care of daca because I'm going to
be doing in the not-too-distant future
pretty soon I'm gonna be signing a new
immigration action very very big
merit-based immigration action that
based on the daca decision I'll be able
to do vastly expand low-skilled
immigration to the United States so they
want a lot of people come in with low
skills
I like merit think of that vastly expand
low-skilled immigration to the United
States these are the things that are in
the plan this is Biden Biden has gone
radical left increase refugee admissions
by seven hundred percent huh
that's a lot by seven hundred percent
nobody's ever heard of such a thing
increase refugee admissions by seven
hundred percent abolish law enforcement
as we know it I think the police do an
incredible job in this country and
you're gonna have a rogue terrible cop
one occasion like you're doing any
industry in any business and any
profession but I think they do an
incredible job abolish law enforcement
as we know it and cash bail no bail just
we let you write up look at what's
happened to New York crime is up
shootings are up at numbers that
nobody's ever seen before look at
Chicago what a disaster and we're
waiting for them to call us because
we're all set to go we have the FBI we
have
Homeland Security we have everybody
ready to go we have the National Guard
they're all ready to go
and cash bail releasing dangerous
criminals onto our streets cash bail New
York just did that other places have
done it they haven't turned out too good
abolish completely the death penalty and
I know there's a lot of debate on the
death penalty and there has been for a
long time but sometimes you use the
death penalty depending on the crime you
know what happened today with regard to
the death penalty appoint social justice
prosecutors in order to free violent
criminals so they want to appoint social
justice prosecutors to free violent
criminals and mandatory minimums and
that's by empowering judges to determine
appropriate sentences by fighting to
repeal mandatory minimums at the federal
level and give States incentives to
repeal their mandatory minimums we could
go on for days incentivize prison
closure so they want to close our
prisons that now want to abolish they
want to polish our Police Department's
they want to abolish our prisons I guess
incentivize jail and prison closures as
populations decline ensure the resources
saved are invested directly into those
communities so they want to close them
rather than have them for some very bad
people people that are not going to
behave when they get add you see that in
New York they allowed a lot of criminals
out and those criminals are causing
havoc and then they got rid of their
incredible and legendary crime squad and
bad things are happening in New York bad
things are happening I Love New York I
hate to see what's going on and solitary
confinement
free federal housing for former inmates
so federal housing now can go to inmates
former inmates rejoin Paris climate
Accord and seek an even higher level of
restrictions oh I didn't notice that oh
I see so they want to rejoin the Paris
climate Accord and they want to seek an
even higher level of restraint in other
words make it worse than it was
mandate net zero carbon emissions for
homes offices and all new buildings by
2030 that basically means no windows no
nothing it's very hard to do I tell
people when they want to go into some of
these buildings how are your eyes
because they won't be good in five years
and I hope you don't mind
cold office space in the winter and warm
office space in the summer because your
air conditioning is not the same as the
good old days mandate zero carbon
emissions from power plants by 2035 zero
who we're talking about zero nothing can
go in the air mandate net zero carbon
emissions by 2050 and I believe he's
changing that he's bringing it down he's
he wants no petroleum product he wants
no oil or gas I don't think Texas is
gonna do too well they're gonna get rid
of about seven million jobs if you go by
the Biden plan I don't think that
Oklahoma North Dakota Pennsylvania
they're gonna be too happy with that and
many other states Ohio mandate all five
hundred thousand school buses and all
three million government vehicles be
changed to zero emission vehicles within
five years I've heard a worse than that
install five hundred thousand
taxpayer-funded charging stations
nationwide here's a bad one really bad
one and school choice there is nothing
that the african-american community
wants more than school choice
and mothers and fathers are going to be
very happy to see him be defeated just
on that alone and school choice so Joe
boy Joe Biden wants to end school choice
in tax credit scholarships serving
disadvantaged students in 26 states
opposed 14 million Americans with
education savings accounts and get rid
of school choice having to do with
school choice eliminate school choice in
Washington DC you know what they've done
in Washington have some incredible
example right here example I know of one
example I think they have a number of
them but one is incredible abolish all
charter schools charter schools are
doing great band funding for charter
schools in poor neighborhoods we don't
want charter schools in poor
neighborhoods well that's not fair
abolish educational standards abolished
in the suburbs you're going to abolish
the sub race with this in force Obama
Biden's radical AFF H that's the AFF H
regulation that threatens to strip
localities of federal affordable housing
funds unless they change their zoning
laws to fit the federal government's
demands so what you have I mean I've
been watching this for years in
Westchester coming from New York they
want a low-income housing built in a
neighborhood well I'm ending that rule
I'm taking it out so I'd spoke with Ben
Carson the other day we're gonna be
taking it out I've watched that whole
thing go and now they want to make it
twice as bad into suburbs into suburbs
mothers aren't happy about that fathers
aren't happy about that they worked hard
to buy a house and now they're going to
watch the housing values drop like a
rock and that has happened drop like a
rock so we're not going to do that we're
going to do the exact opposite probably
there has never been a time and this is
just a few this is
it's much worse than that we did this
very quickly it's probably never been a
time when candidates are so different we
want law and order
they don't want Lauren order we want
strong close borders with people able to
come in through merit through a legal
process they don't want to have any
borders at all they got to rip down the
wall it was hard to get that built and
now it's almost completed it'll be
completed by a little after the end of
the year they want to rip it down and
it's had such an impact it's incredible
it stops trafficking human trafficking
of women and children but women mostly
human trafficking one of the worst
things ever all at a level that it's
never been at because of the internet
you wouldn't think you think of it as an
ancient statement you wouldn't think
that's possible today but it's human
trafficking of women and children and
they want to let that good continue that
the wall has stopped it so much because
they will go over to a section where
there aren't people not an entry point
and they'll make a left into the United
States they're on their way they can't
do that anymore we have a 30-foot wall
that goes six feet into the ground it
stops a lot of the tunneling because
they're pretty good at tunnels but we
watch the tunnels and we have equipment
for that but you can't make a left
anymore and come into the United States
load it up with human traffic so they
want to take down the wall they want to
have open borders think of open borders
today though with the pandemic I mean
the timing is sort of interesting but
with the pandemic so there's never been
a time when two candidates were so
different I mean I've seen graces where
it's like the same exact platforms I'm
even talking about essentially Democrat
Republican is not that much difference
is a little difference but there's not
much you choose one because you like the
way they look you like the way they
sound you like the way they talk you
like something about one and you don't
like the other but there's you know
they've never been a difference here's
one of the greatest different this is
when
question the single biggest difference
if you want law and order for instance I
enacted recently when I saw that was
going on with federal monuments we don't
have the right to do States although
we're going to trying to find it but
with the monuments where they wanted to
rip down Andrew Jackson they wanted to
rip down George Washington they were
actually heading over to the Jefferson
Memorial if you can believe that but
this has been going on and I found an
act that we've used and we have many
many people in jail right now many many
people in jail all over the country
because they tried to destroy or in some
cases got got it down a federal statue
or monument we haven't had anybody
making a move since I enacted this I
signed an executive order of a couple of
weeks ago and it says very simply ten
years in jail you do it ten years in
jail the amazing part is we were able to
catch everybody because thanks to all of
you on television we appreciate it but
we have their pictures we have the man
standing on Andrew Jackson's horse we
have the man standing by General George
Washington we have everybody standing at
over they were going to go for the
Emancipation Proclamation Abraham
Lincoln standing with a young man who
was being freed and we said we're gonna
do something we can't let this happen
now it could be removed at some point
you go through a process a legal process
go through Congress whatever I
understand that at the same time some
people like these statues and monuments
but it can be removed but you have to go
through a legal process so they were
going to have 20 to 25,000 people that
night nobody showed up nobody you know
that because you were disappointed to
see that the next night I believe 22
people showed up they said we're going
to make it Friday night instead
and 22 people showed up four were
actually arrested because we have
pictures of them knocking down other
statues so they're in jail down so there
has never been an election where we've
had this kind of difference we want
strong borders without borders you've
heard me say it a thousand times without
borders you don't have a country they
don't want to have borders they want to
have open borders it's radical left and
it'll destroy our country 20 years ago
Venezuela was a very rich country one of
the richest one of the richest anywhere
per capita one of the richest tremendous
oil reserves now they don't have water
they don't have food they don't have
medicine we do everything we can to take
care of the people but they have nothing
and that's exactly the ideology that you
have going over here if I wasn't there
to stop it if I wasn't here to say no
way that's not gonna happen
we'd be in some mess would be in some
mess and Pelosi and Schumer and Bernie
and Joe they'll never stop it they don't
have the power the strength to stop it
it's beyond them but we do so there's
never been a time like this where you've
had an election of people so different
okay couple of questions yet please good
better part of an hour explaining why
Americans should choose you and not your
opponent yesterday you said on Twitter
be careful what you wish for guess the
question is do you see yourself as the
underdog in this race do you see
yourself losing in the fall no I don't I
think we have really good poll numbers
they're not suppression polls they're
real polls you look at the intercoastal
in Florida you look at the lakes you see
thousands of boats with Trump signs
American signs you've got the Trump in
sign all over you look at what's going
on you look at bikers for miles and
miles writing up highways proudly with
their signs
I have look we want to race where it was
the same thing 2016 we had polls that
were fake they turned out to be fake not
at all a couple of them got it right
three of them to be exact three of them
one of them was unsuspecting but they
got it right they were very proud of it
but we had in 2016
something even more so but we got in and
we had 306 - I guess 223 which was a
tremendous margin of difference you
remember they all said he cannot get to
270 I went to Maine a number of times
where we just freed up lobster fishing
and fishing because they took away 5,000
square miles from Maine I just opened it
up and I just got rid of tariffs in
China and we're working on European
Union which charged our fishermen
tariffs and I said you're not going to
do that so we freed it up for me but if
you take a look we went up there
recently there were crowds thousands of
people lined up going over to a factory
where we were opening up for we're
making swaps a beautiful big new factory
making swaps I think that the enthusiasm
now is greater and maybe far greater
than it was in 2016 I think a lot of
people don't want to talk about it I
think they're not going to say hey I'm
for Trump on for Trump they don't want
to go through the process and I fully
understand that because the process is
not fair the media doesn't treat us
fairly they never have and perhaps they
never will but maybe they will when we
turned this around for a second time and
it's going to happen very quickly when
we turn it around for a second time
maybe they will I think we're doing very
well in the polls and I think you have a
silent majority the likes of which this
country has never seen before this is a
very important election we've done a
great job we had to turn it off as I
said turn it off and now we've started
it again as you know they announced two
weeks ago record job numbers almost 5
million people and that beat the last
month which was also a record 2.8
million people nobody's ever done what
we
done and now we're doing it twice and I
think by Election Day you're gonna see
some incredible numbers the third
quarter is going to be really good
fourth quarter is going to be great but
next year is going to be one of the best
economic years so hopefully I'll be able
to be the president where we say look at
the great job I did at this point I
think great I think we have a great
chance I think we're gonna have a lot of
people show up I'm very worried about
mail-in voting because I think it's
subject to tremendous fraud and being
rigged you see that Paterson New Jersey
where I believe it was 20% of the vote
was fraudulent it was all sorts of
things happened I understand a am
ailment was recently indicted someplace
for playing games with the mail-in
ballots you'll have tremendous fraud if
you do these mail-in ballots now
absentee ballots are okay because
absentee ballots you have to get
applications you have to go through a
process if I'm here and I vote in
Florida you get an absentee ballot but
you have to go through a process
absentee ballots are great but mail-in
voting where a governor mails millions
of ballots to people all over the state
California millions and millions of
ballots is an exam and then they come
back they don't come back who got him
did you forget to send them to a
Republican area or a Democrat area I
guess you could say but if you take a
look at all of the unbelievable fraud
that's been involved with mail-in voting
over the last even short period of well
but look at Paterson New Jersey it was a
massive era and a massive miscalculation
and there was incredible fraud look at
the City Council what's happened to it
this is one place but you have many
places and they're all over yes please
thank you sir I want to know when's the
last time you spoke with president G of
China and do you plan to speak with him
in the near future no I haven't spoken
to one no I don't have no plan to speak
to him just wanted to Ruth Bader begins
Berg was hospitalized today with an
infection and want to know if you had
any reaction to that do you know I wish
you're the best
I hope she's better I didn't hear that
actually she was just hospitalized no
that's too bad no I wish her the best
she's actually giving me some good
rulings okay so you know that right
people were surprised no I wish you the
absolute best please Thank You mr.
president
so you were mentioned the travel bans
and I wonder when do you plan to reveal
that because their European countries
and in a situation is under control much
a better place than the US and there is
no ban for all their hotspots like
Russia and India so what will be the
criteria to change that
you know we banned for Europe and at
some point that'll come off and we're
dealing with them all the time the
relationships are good they just don't
treat us very well on trade they are
they have been very unfair to us over
many many decades and we're doing that
it's very easy to solve I was all set to
solve it actually and then we got hit
with the the plague but we have a travel
ban on various countries and that travel
ban remains until such time as we say it
doesn't repay anyone our country safe we
don't want to like Biden we don't want
to have criminals pouring into our
country we don't want to have open
borders we're not gonna have that and we
want to take care of our police we want
to actually fund our police not defund
them and we're not going to abolish our
police and we're not going to make our
military small and weak because probably
or at least at top of the level we need
our military right now yeah go ahead
please very so how do you think that the
America first policy can work during a
pandemic aren't you were concerned that
this could actually damage the US and
make China more influence around the
world okay look my policies America
first we've lost hundreds of billions of
dollars a year with China and many other
countries and what we're doing is just
handing everybody everything it's just
said I've watched it I've looked at it
we did the us/mexico you saw that USMC a
we made a very fair deal on trade where
the worst deal ever
right you know that we had the worst
deal ever and it replaced that it
replaced that horrible NAFTA deal that
was one of the worst trade deals ever
made I'll tell you the only deal that
might be worse is the WTO World Trade
Organization maybe worse Oh a end please
Thank You mr. president your
administration has taken tangible steps
to ensure that Chinese companies are not
taking advantage of our US stock market
our trade last week your administration
sent a letter to the Railroad Retirement
Board
olara asking them to reconsider
investments in Chinese defense firms
meaning not to invest correct so where
is that request now and are you taking
tangible actions to ensure that US
investments don't continue to find
defense firms in China you'll see more
coming this was a very important bill
that we signed but you're going to see
more coming over the next short period
of time but yes we don't want them
investing in Chinese military companies
okay letters I mean what actions can be
taken to ensure that does not help well
you have a lot of actions we can take
including the including the increase you
know right now people don't know China's
paying a lot of tests we made a China
deal and they bought just I think the
third highest amount of corn ever and I
think in the world history they just
bought from us the highest amount which
is great for our farmers but I view it
differently than I did before I made the
deal when I made the deal I thought this
was a great deal after what happened to
us what happened to the world coming
from China I view it much differently
but we can impose massive tariffs so in
China if we want and other countries if
we want and will see we just want to be
treated fairly we want a level playing
field our farmers were never treated
properly
anybody and they were targeted by China
and I paid our farmers 28 billion
dollars over a two year period because
they were targeted to that amount of
money to that exact amount of money 28
it was 16 billion and it was 12 billion
28 over a two-year period and we gave 28
billion dollars to our farmers that's
why they're all here and now they're
doing very well our farmers are doing
very well because we've made really
great trade deals us MCA just kicked in
the China deal they're buying a lot they
are buying a lot you will say that
they're buying a lot a lot of people ask
how are they doing on the trade deal
they're buying a lot so I want to thank
everybody and we'll be having these
conferences again I what we're going to
be signing an immigration act very soon
it's going to be based on merit it's
going to be very strong we're going to
work on daca because we want to make
people happy and I'll tell you even
conservative Republicans want to see
something happen with daca the Democrats
had their chance for three years to do
something with daca and they always
turned it down they always turned to
dead they used it as politics I'm using
it to get something done but we'll be
signing a very powerful immigration act
it'll be great it'll be merit-based the
countries tried to get it for 25 or 30
years it'll be strong on the border but
you'll come in Legally and you'll be
able to come in Legally and very
importantly we'll be taking care of
people from daca in a very Republican
way Republicans I've spoken to many
Republicans and some would like to leave
it out but really they understand that
it's the right thing to do so we're
gonna be taking care of daca we will be
doing for daca what the Democrats had a
chance to do and they never did it okay
thank you all very much
[Music]
[Applause]